so we had these these revelations about
Roy Moore Republican Senate candidate in
Alabama running for Jeff Sessions a seat
accused of child sexual assault by a
then fourteen-year-old we talked about
Sean Hannity and other Republican
defenders we talked about people like
Mitt Romney saying the guy is unfit he's
got to step down but how is it impacting
the race well we have a new Senate poll
where Democrat Doug Jones is leading
Republican Roy Moore in the state of
Alabama in the race for Donald Trump's
attorney general Jeff Sessions is old
Senate seat this is the first poll that
shows Doug Jones having a lead
it has Jones up 46 to 42 this poll was
done by JMC analytics after the
reporting of the child sex assault
allegations surfaced against Roy Moore
now it's 46 42 but it has a 4% margin of
error so statistically this is still a
tie and my concern is is there an
element of the Bradley effect if the
Bradley effect is real not everybody
believes that the Bradley effect is real
the Bradley effect is the idea that you
might have people who are afraid or
embarrassed to tell pollsters that
they're still planning to vote for the
alleged child sexual assault er and it
was named after Tom Bradley who was the
former african-american mayor of Los
Angeles and in 1982 he ran for governor
of California and he was depending on
what you look at either slightly ahead
or doing well in the polls on Election
Day
or exit polls on election day were
showing him ahead and he ultimately lost
and this was attributed by many people
to the idea that they weren't really
gonna vote for a black guy and they
wouldn't vote for a black guy but they
wanted to appear to be not racist
something called the social desirability
bias where people are more likely to
answer questions the way they believe
would would see them most favorably
viewed by society however there are
people who say there's no such thing as
the Bradley effect they say no what
would happen was a lot of Republicans
voted absentee in California and 82 so
the exit polls were heavily skewed
towards the in-person voters who were
Democrats so that there was not
this Bradley effect anyway it's not
universally accepted but that's one
question right when you see a lot of
undecideds and there's close to 10%
undecided in this poll you might wonder
well are people just not willing to say
I'm still going to vote for the child
sex assault er we'll see we'll see and
in fact there are some other polls and
there was another poll that came out
from decision desk HQ which has it at 46
46 with fewer undecideds there are other
polls which still have ROI more slightly
ahead what's clear though is that more
support has gone down now the other
thing I do want to mention is that
there's an internal here from the JMC
analytics poll which shows that 37% of
evangelical Christians that were
surveyed 37% say they are more likely to
vote for ROI more after news broke of
his child sexual assault allegations and
that gets me to something that I was
hoping wouldn't be true but it's not
hugely shocking which is that look
evangelicals voted for Trump when Trump
is ostensibly the opposite of what
evangelical Christians really should be
voting for and they are still going to
mostly vote for Roy Moore as well there
are Alabama Republicans who are going to
be in the position which for them will
be very difficult of having to decide am
I more repulsed by voting for an alleged
child sex abuse err or am I more
repulsed by voting for a Democrat and
for many Alabama Republicans as we are
we are already seeing from voter
interviews that are being done by CNN
and others a lot of them would rather
vote for the alleged child sex abuse err
than for a Democrat and fundamentally
Roy Moore is what Republicans are more
than we'd like to admit and I think that
we've got to come to terms with that and
just get involved in this race to the
extent that we can I've been saying it
for months right do it phone bank donate
knock on doors if you live in Alabama
because taking this seat away from
Republicans would be so huge no matter
what happens in 2018 right strategically
mathematically we can figure all that
out but the idea
that Trump already regrets hiring Jeff
Sessions because he wants somebody who's
not recused from the Russia stuff as
Attorney General if on top of that
Donald Trump's decision to hire Jeff
Sessions led to a Democrat taking this
Alabama seat that would just be so great
I would absolutely love it so get
involved in this race donate phonebank
do whatever you can send me your
thoughts on Twitter about it I'm on
Twitter at D Pakman the show is on
Twitter at David Pakman show today's
episode of the David Pakman show is made
possible in part by Warby Parker
eyeglasses Warby Parker recently did the
right thing and ditched advertising on
right-wing conspiracy website Breitbart
pulling their ads off and you can get
the free five-day home Tryon from Warby
Parker check out their glasses I use
them when I'm not wearing contact lenses
I started with the free at-home trial
they send you five pairs of glasses you
see which ones you like you send them
back and whichever one you pick they
will put your prescription in - I like
this because I can actually show the
glasses to other people and not have to
just decide on the spot like in an
eyeglass store the eyeglass industry is
controlled by very few corporations that
keep the prices very very high even over
$300 for prescription glasses with Warby
Parker they start at just 95 bucks mine
costs that including lenses and for
every pair sold they give a pair to
someone in need so to try the five pairs
and support the David Pakman show go to
Warby Parker trial comm /t DPS